can per move which kicks off at move 41
and they are ready to go
oh
look at this oh
gambit i played it when i was a kid not
knight f3 i was playing even bishop c4
which is not considered so well
knight f3 so they are just absolutely in
the mood okay
knight f6 and i have to say one thing um
the pomegranate recently released a
chessable course on the king's gabbat
uh-huh things yeah so that's uh that's
how he started to play this one
d6
queen e2 on the board
so this game definitely not going to be
a boring one definitely not
and
so whilst the players are thinking and
considering their moves i have to tell
you a funny story about the king's
gambit
one of my grandmaster friends wrote a
book on the on the king's gambit and you
know he really worked super hard on it
and he discovered that
what's best chance is lay not in an
attack but in swapping off all the
pieces
and winning the end game
and he got so many complaints from the
readers they said we don't want to read
about this positional advantage in an
endgame we just want to see the attacks
we want to see the sacrifices
okay
so okay talking about sacrifices they
are coming look at that dtx e5
queen
look at this what is really going on
here
wow it's full firework
and look at this it looks so nice for
white so nice for white so beautiful
18th century game knight comes to f2 c3
long castle
bishop g2
and look at the pieces sorry i didn't
show this today yet but
fabulous
okay
so that has happened well it's like uh
so bishop e6 is of course blocking the
powerful queen
here so i'm expecting knight c3
knight c3 is is the move that has been
analyzed
knight c3 or even c for me but i i'm
expecting ah knight c3 on the board of
course what else
white wants to play long castle all the
pieces are in action yep
ready to give checkmate just in a few
moves scary scary to death exactly
oh no this game will not last more than
20 moves
it looks fantastic for the pomegranate
and
okay so how can
perugia even attempt to survive this
well he's already under 10 minutes
nearly half of the time of
napo wow
yeah and i can tell you just the bar
isn't it just running all the way yep
the computer is looking at it
plus three i still have my feelings
about the king's gambit okay when this
all these pieces are in the center
i mean this side would be happy to play
as
i'm okay with this position
yeah
and it's only move 11.
we have a queen on h1 which probably
will be trapped
okay
so
yeah you don't get these kind of
positions too often
so what's white's uh idea so if like the
bishop comes out to d6 so i don't really
want to analyze too much because
it has three and a half minutes let's
say bishop d6 in any case white castles
the problem is that the black queen
simply cannot move
so in the next move white is going to
play bishop g2 if black goes bishop ce5
i think white can just take between e5
g7 is hanging c7 is hanging bishop b5
discovery check is is right there if
knight d7 i think uh white is not even
going to
take the pawn but plays bishop b5 after
the d5 and the pin is here
so
it's like
g5 happened okay
trying to save himself and
look for some conte chances maybe the
idea is that after bishop g5 queen g1 or
something but even knight e4 will be
here coming and playing a knight f6
check of course queen b5 is there any
time
so
after g5 already i think white has
several options
to continue the game
yeah the line that you showed just lit
crushing um
yeah i don't see any anything but he
goes deeply five he's just enjoying
himself i think i you don't get such a
position every day not even every year
one c
[Laughter]
i mean it's still possible to ruin it of
course because you can ruin everything
so after g takes f4 i think white is
ready to take on e6 and then pawn takes
and pawn takes time to cast so long
and simply the real problem is on the
black squares bishop g2 queen on h5
queen on b5 pawn on e6 is just deadly so
yeah if you get a
yeah if you get a bishop to g2 it's just
game over i mean the queen will come to
b5 everything will drop off okay we have
some g takes f4
on the board d takes f
okay
pawn takes pawn is in the uh
white is going to castle on the next
okay so what does he play bishop
he plays bishop d6
well
and now the question is long castle
knight f7 pawn takes f7
i mean there are quite several moves i
think long castle will be the move
i like long castle i'd bet on that
i definitely like castling long
and
wow
well if uh
if let's say nepo would not win this
game this would be
very difficult meant to be to adjust to
that knight f7 is also a killer i think
yeah just to keep you posted as well on
the magnus cause in our entire game
magnus has just blundered so there's a
magnus has just blunted against
aryantari so aryan has a killer blow on
the board but let's go back to this game
oops
uh long castle
we were waiting for this check
all our lives okay so i said under move
20 yeah
but this is tv no
[Music]
you're allowed to
you're allowed to say things
no but it's not far away you know i
don't know if
okay i don't think i exaggerated knight
f6 knight c6
trying to save himself of course who
else if not firoza who is a great
fighter and he can save with miracles
if someone
well knight c6 doesn't look bad but
probably after knight c6 black is just
going to take check with f takes g3 here
and goes castle
and then says okay i'm not losing a move
20 am out of that
[Laughter]
at least
well now it's a question whether knight
f7 maybe night at night seven looks nice
doesn't have a knight of servants okay
on the board
queen e6
ah he plans long castle this was not
expected in this game from black
okay no bishop c4 queen e3 check king b1
no castle for black
castle for black knight takes work is
happening queen takes porn is happening
it's just
total disaster for ferugia
and how many moves are we
18. 18. he's going to get out of 20.
and also farisha has only one and a half
minutes almost also queen the queen
throwing to the other side to check h5
is also does not look too bad
looks looks crushing
yeah
and
firoza has under a minute in a second i
know
i think knight d6 i would go knight d6
takes and queen b7
yep
but also can you also can you play queen
takes queen and then go knight takes no
maybe not maybe no no no you don't want
to go into end game in this position
you would think it's either you give
mate or you win the game with the queens
or yes it was not worth doing it
[Laughter]
yeah i like your idea knight takes
bishop
i mean i i think that's uh
yeah one takes queen
i'm queen c4
takes black goes to 98
well okay but this is completely okay
it's on the board knight takes bishop
pawn takes
knight and now we're expecting queen
takes no question about it no question
about it instantly plays queen takes
bishop
move 20.
well that's a good that's good news for
faresa it will not make that book of
miniatures
no but every chess player hates to be in
no but
i have doubts that he will be able to
save it
queen a8 knight d8 we were here before
now knight e4 is also very strong though
then black can go castle rookie one king
f7 black will not castle in this game
check on a7 i think
there are
queen checks so white has a pawn up
to say the least but that's not the only
problem of black in this game
g takes f4 the king is in is completely
a full danger queen c5 but this is
something queen e7 or something gonna be
the move and
then
first okay even better
and then check check check check check
game over
yeah
wow what an
impressive
game shall we run through the beginning
again because that was
maybe together with the nepo and he's
going to be coming i think